brian nevada's vaccination rollout began
more than a month ago and our state
continues to lag behind
in vaccinating nevadans the i-team's
vanessa murphy has been trying to find
out why
the number of doses nevada is receiving
from the federal government
is much lower than other states and we
don't have
a clear answer why leaders of the
vaccination program here say
they don't know why either as of this
afternoon the cdc reports nevada second
to last in doses received from the
federal government
for every 100 000 people we're receiving
more than
11 000 doses but take a look at alaska
one of the least
populated states it's at the top with
more than
26 000 doses per 100 000 people
as we reported on january 24th governor
steve siselek sent a letter to the u.s
department of health and human services
asking for clarification about why
nevada is getting such a
low number of covid 19 vaccination doses
the kovid 19 response director says his
team is continuing to work with the
biden administration
there was a call this morning with
governors but again
still no clear answer why we
at the program level had made the
request
through our cdc uh project officer
and so we have not received the actual
formula at the program level
but i do know you know with the support
of our federal delegation they have
been asking a lot of questions the
i-team reached out to fema to find out
more and
twice a representative referred us back
to nevada
also lags behind in getting doses into
the arms of nevadans
here in clark county we're still in the
70 and over age group for the general
population lane
i asked what needs to happen to speed
this up
again the state continues to blame the
federal government
while we have many doses reported not
yet
used more on that coming up at 6.
vanessa murphy 8 news now
also a warning from nevada's vaccination
team beware of scams
only provide information to your health
care provider
or the health department you will not be
charged for the coven 19 vaccine but
your insurance
may be built